よろしくお願いします
チャッタリマニ
ビッカヴェー ジャヤンティ カタマニ チャッタリ ピーマー ピーマン ジャヤティ ピーマー ドーソー ジャヤ
ティ ドーサー ピーマン ジャヤティ ドーサー ドーソー ジャヤティ
で この経典のテーマというかタイトルですね
あの四種類のものが生まれてくるんだというのが
チャッタリっていうのは四種類ですね
四つのものが生まれてくるということで
この四つは何なのかとカタマニ チャッタリ
ピーマー ピーマン ジャヤティ
愛着から愛着が生まれる
愛着が愛着を生み出すということ
ピーマー ドーソー ジャヤンティ
愛着が怒りを生み出す
愛着が愛着を生み出す
ドーサー ピーマン ジャヤティ
怒りから愛着が生まれる
次 ドーサー ドーソー ジャヤティ
怒りから怒りが生まれると
それがタイトルで お釈迦様がこのすごいこのごく一般の方々に
一般人に 普通の農民の普通の仕事をして
まあそんなに教育とか知識とかそんなのある人々ではなくて
一般的な普通の人々に
あの わかるように 理解できるように
かなり説法なさったんですから
まあまあそれもそんなに難しい教典ではないと思います
皆様にはなんてつまらないという風にも感じるかもしれませんけど
そこら辺はちょっと理解しておいた方がいいんです
それはもうごっつい知識人にガチャガチャガチャガチャとエスカゴロンで語るんではなくて
まあごく一般的な まあ文字も書けない
読めない まあごく普通の昔の人々に語り続けた教えであると
そういうことで 皆様に役に立つことがあれば大変ありがたいんですけど
役に立つことなかったら
それはそれでよろしいと思います
それでこの覚えやすいんですよ
愛着と憎しみという二言がありまして
その二言葉 愛着と憎しみ
愛着から愛着が生まれる
愛着から憎しみが生まれる
次に憎しみから愛着が生まれる
憎しみから憎しみが生まれると
四つなんです まあ一応すごいわかりやすいと思います
で それからお釈迦様の説明があります
カタンチャ
ビッカヴェー ピーマー ピーマン ジャヤティ イダ ビッカヴェー プッガロー プッガラッサ イットー カン
トー イットー ホーティ カントー マナーポー タンプレー イッテーナ カンテーナ マナーテーナ サムダーチ
ャランティー タッサ エワンホーティー ヨーコーミャヤン プッガロー イットー カントー マナーポー タン
プレー イッテーナ カンテーナ マナーテーナ サムダーチャランティーティ ソーテス ピーマン ジャネーティ エワン
コー ビッカヴェー ピーマー ピーマン ジャヤティ
カタンチャ ビッカヴェー ピーマー ピーマン ジャヤティ
愛着から愛着が生まれるということはどういうことでしょうかと
イダ ビッカヴェー ここでプッガロー
人がいるとします プッガラッサ イットー ホーティ カントー マナーポー
ここである人がいる その人がある人に対して大変気に入られている
イットー カントー マナーポーというのはものすごく気に入っているふうな意味なんですね
文章は長いんだけど 愛着がありますということで
それで ある人がある人のこと
ものすごく気になり 気に入っている
その人のことをすごく楽しくて
喜んで気に入っているのは愛着が生まれているということなんですね
そこでその気に入られている人が
タンプレー イッテーナ カンテーナ マナーテーナ サムダーチャランティ
自分が気に入っている人が
例えば自分に対して随分気に入っている
気に入られる行為をする
イッテーナ カンテーナ マナーテーナ サムダーチャランティ
自分に接する 自分が好きな人がいて
この好きな人が自分に対して好きなように接すると
なかなか分かりにくいでしょうね
一般の普通の人間だったら
これすごい簡単に分かります
現代の方々に理解させるのは難しいかもしれませんだけどね
まあ難しいことではないと思いますけどね
今の人々にはね あの人のことを好きということは全くないんだから
なかなか難しいんですけどね
だからこれはもうごく一般の方々に語った教典だから
やっぱり理解難しいと思いますよ
現代の方が もうすごい
まあだから単純な例えは思い出せないんで
例えっていうのは皆さん分かってる世界から言わなくちゃいけないんだから
[背景音楽]私にならいっぱいありますけどね
もう あの隣のペットショップにすごい可愛いワンちゃんがいたんで
犬が見たら私はすごい可愛いなと思ったんです
なんて可愛い子でかなとね
買ってやりたいなと思って
そこで窓ガラスからワンちゃんと見ていたんですね
そこでその子はものすごく喜んで遊ぶはもういろんなことやってるんです
で 私に対してあれこれと
いろんなこと 自分知ってる噂やら何でも見せたりする
それさらにすごい楽しくなっちゃうんですね
で 離れなくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱりすごくやっぱり可愛いとものすごい喜んで遊ぶわ遊ぶわ遊ぶわもう歩く回るは飛び上がるはもうもう檻の中だからそんなことできないんですけど
まあ必死なんですね だから私がすごい可愛いなと思ったし
向こうも私が好きなように接する
こっちが喋っても喋ってもあっち向いて全然お前のこと気にしないぞと思っちゃうと
別にそれとは違うんです
そんなもんで そういう経験あるならば
もう言ってることはわかると思います
あの人すごくいいなと思った人が
自分に対してすごくニコッと笑ったり
すごくもう挨拶をしたり
遊んでくれたり そういうことをしてくれると
もうさらにあの愛着が増えてくるということで
愛着から愛着が生まれるんだと
タッ
スエーバンゴティヨーコウミャーヤンポッゲローイットーカントーマナーポータンパレーイッテーナカンテーナマナーテーナサムダーチャランティーティテースペーマンジャネーティ
で その人はこういう風に考える
私に私にはすっごく気に入ってるこの人が私に対してすっごい気に入る接し方をしているんだと
そういうことで もう初めから欲が愛着があったんですけど
それ愛着に基づいてさらに愛着が生まれてくる
2番目に行きます カタンチャビッカーウェーピーマドゥスージャエーティ
愛着からどのように怒りが生まれるのかと
イダビッカーウェーポッゲローポッゲラッセイットーホーティカントーマナーポー
ある人に ある人のことをものすごく気に入っている
まあ好きでたまらないと
かっこいいと なんて美しい人ですかとか
そういうふうに思っている
タンパレーアニッテーナアカンテーナアマナーテーナサムダーチャランティ
しかし その人がものすごい嫌な接し方をする
怒鳴ったり けなしたり
バカにしたり 無視したりする
そうすると彼がこう考えるんですね
私はそのあのこの人のことを好きなんですけど
その人はもう好きなのに
私に対していつでも失礼で
もうもうけなしたり 非難したり
侮辱したり バカにしたり
いろんなことをやってるんだと言って腹が立つんです
だから すごい強烈に怒りが出ている
その怒りがあの人のことを好きだから出てきたんですね
それで怒りは欲情 愛着から怒りが生まれる
そこで私はこの難しく現代時代では難しく感じるポイントですから
ちょっと分かりやすくしたんですけど
もうちょっとお釈迦様取っているのがもうちょっと微妙に違うんです
そこを言っちゃうとさらに分かりにくく
分かりにくくなりますからね
一応これから言わなくちゃならないんです
私は Aさんのことが好き
Aさんが他の人に対してもすごい優しい態度で接したりする
自分に対してというわけじゃないんです
誰に対してもすごく親切で
行儀よく振る舞いをする
そうすると 私はもともと Aさんのことを好きですから
やっぱり Aさんといいなといい人やと私は思った通りの人やということで思うんです
それが愛着から愛着が生まれることなんですね
それはお釈迦様にとって意味はそういう意味なんです
それはわからないでしょう
だから自分が好きな人がいるという経験もないんだから
だから自分が好きになった人が自分に対してすごい好きな態度をすると
一応気に入られる さらにさらに好きになるんです
それはすごい単純でわかりやすいと思いますけど
だから犬の例をなんか出しましたけど
でも自分が好きな犬が自分と遊ぶんじゃなくて
他の人と遊ぶと 現代人っていうのは腹が立つと思いますけどね
だからそこはちょっとわかりにくいところなんですけど
お釈迦様はいうのは  AさんがBさんのことはすごく気に入っている
Bさんが人に対してすごい親切に優しく態度を取る
そうすると  Aさんがもうさらに Bさんのことは好きになる
あるいは逆に Bさんのことを好き
Bさんが自分が好きです
人に対してすごい失礼な厳しい態度で喋ったり行動したりする
そうすると Aさんがもう腹が立つんですね
なんでそんなことをするんですかと
ということで怒るんです
例えば 母親が自分の子供のことをすごく好き
自分の子供はどんな人にもすごい丁寧に挨拶をする
人が質問なんかしたらすごい丁寧に返事をする
人に対してすごい行儀よく
自分の子供が他人に対して行儀よく振る舞うと
母親の愛着がさらに増えるんですよ
やっぱりすごくいい子やと
ものすごいお利口さんやと
自分が思ってるというよりもすごいお利口さんやというふうに思う可能性あります
そういう機能なんですね
逆に自分の子供だから
自分はすっごく好きでもうしっかり育てたい気持ちでいるんですけど
人に対しては乱暴でものすごい行儀が悪いと
そうすると母親が腹が立つんですよ
なんでそんなことするんですかと
挨拶したらどうですか？と
で 怒りがこみ上げてくる
3番目 カタンチャビッカウィドーサピーマンジャヤティ
怒りから愛着は生まれることはどういうことでしょうか
イダビッカウィプッグループンジャラッサアニットホーティアカントアマナコ
そこで自分がすごく気に入ってない
自分に対してはもう嫌な人がいる
一切悪い人間やと信頼できない人やと
嫌だ それは自分がものすごい嫌だって思っている人は
他人に対してもものすごい侮辱的な
失礼な態度で接している
そうするとなんかその人のことで喜びが生まれてくるんですね
誰に対して喜びが生まれるかで
自分が嫌な人に対して愛着が生まれるんじゃなくて
やられてる側に対して仲間意識が出てくるんです
例えば 学校で自分の子供をある子供がいじめている
そうするといじめて子供に対してはすごく怒りがこみ上げてくる
それでその子は自分の子供だけじゃなくて
他の子供をいじめている
そうすると 自分の子供にある愛着と同じ愛着が他の次の被害者に対しても生まれてくるんですね
被害者同士で あるいは親同士でも
いじめられている親たちがお互いにもうすごい仲良くするんです
そこで仲良くすることができたのは怒りなんです
いじめる子に対するすごい怒りなんです
大体被害者たちがいろいろ自分たちで仲良く組合作るんですよ
お互いすごく仲良くしているんです
被害者組合作って 被害者と言った途端もう憎しみなんですよ
だから誰かを憎しむことにことから
こちらが愛着が生まれる
我々仲間は一致団結してなんとかしなくちゃいけないんだと
お互いはすごい仲がいいんです
心配もする これ この愛着がなぜ生まれたかというと
誰かを憎しむことから生まれたんです
例えば 自分が嫌な人が自分にだけ被害を与えて
誰にも被害を与えてない場合は
そういう被害者同士の組合ができ上がらないんですね
自分だけ一人だからね
四番目のケースはそれなんです
カタンチャ ビックリ ドーサ ドーソ ジャヤティ
怒りから怒りが生まれるってことはどういうことかと
イダ ビックリ プックル プックラス アニット ホーティ アカント アマナポ
ある人のことはすっごい気に入らない
もうものすごく憎しみがあるんですね
タン パレ 一定な観点にマナティにサマダ ジャヤティ
しかし その人は他人に対してはものすごい立派な人なんですね
ものすごい行儀よく振りまうんです
自分がものすごい憎しみでも嫌な人やと思ってるんだけど
その人は人に対してはすごい親切で
ものすごい行儀がいいんです
だから被害は自分にだけなんですね
そうすると彼がものすごい怒るんです
さらに だから自分の子供をいじめる子は
他の子供とすごい仲良くしている
協力したりする 助けたりもすると
というと 決してこの被害者の親があの子供たちの親と仲良くすることはしないんですよ
怒るんです みんな嫌な連中やと
だから自分にだけ被害を与えて
他人に被害をしないと
もうもうすごい怒りがそれによってどんどんどんどんこみ上げて膨張していくんです
なぜかと自分にはあの人は悪い人やと思う
もう言いたいんだけど
証人もいないんだからね
何人かが証人証言してくれるならば
私も被害を受けたと 私も被害を受けたというならば楽々なそれで気持ちは気分がいいんですよ
そうすると証言する人のことをすごく気に入るんです
大事にするんです それで他の親たちにあなた方は証言してくださいと
あの子はものすごいいじめっ子やと言って
いえいえ そんなことはないんだよと
ものすごくいい子だよと言っちゃうと腹が立つんです
実際に自分の子をいじめているんだから
そんなこと言ったって私の子をいじめられているんだよと
まあそう言ったって 私たちの子供に対してすごい親切だから
これはどうしようもないんだと
あんた一人で何かやってくださいと協力できんと
あんな優しい子に対して証言しちゃうとね
まずいと 言っちゃうと
もうみんなに対して怒りが増えていっちゃうんですね
だから怒りから怒りが生まれるっていうことは
そういうことなんです
これは別な古い教典の注釈なんですけどね
この教典は  [背景音楽]だからこの経典の元になった経典を調べないと
ちょっと連絡がつかないんです
まあだいたいまあそれぐらい覚えておけば
残りは別に皆様にはそれほど関係も興味のあるものではあるものやとはちょっと思いにくいんです
この四つの働きをちょっと理解していただければ
このすごいありがたいことで
愛着は愛着か愛着が愛着を生まれる作ることもあるし
愛着が憎しみを作ることもあるし
憎しみが愛着を作ることもあるし
憎しみが憎しみを作ることもあるということで
だから自分の心の愛着
自分の心にある憎しみをどのように生まれたかと調べてみると
それが愛着から生まれたものか
あるいは憎しみから生まれたものかということも
まあいろいろな発見できると思います
それで その弱みをいつなくなるのかと
愛着から愛着も生まれないし
愛着から憎しみも生まれないし
憎しみから愛着も生まれないし
憎しみから憎しみも生まれない状態っていうのはどういう状態か
いわゆる心をすごい進んでいる状態なんです
普通はなかなかできないと思いますけど
だいたい元気で生きてる人々の場合は
まあよく普通に経験ですよ
で 生きていても死んでる場合はなかなかね
もうそういう愛着も憎しみも何もわからない
もうすごい無関心で ただロボットみたいにね
ご飯食べて もう仕事に行って
帰ってお風呂に入ってご飯を食べて寝るぐらいの人生だったらね
自分でも何をやっているのかとわからないっていうのは
それはまあやっぱり生きてないんですね
元気で明るくて生きてるという人にとっては
明るい人だったらどうせ憎しみもあるんです
すごく明るくてニコニコとみんなと優しく活発に生きてる人は
ものすごく怒って まああれやこれやとかね
喧嘩したりすることも当然あります
だからまあ これよく理解できるのは
そこすごいごく普通にすごい明るく生きてる人々の場合なんですね
皆様にしても 死ぬ前に子供の時期ありましたから
すごい小さい時は一応日本の方々も生きているんですね
その時はすごい喜びも子供には憎しみも両方あるんですね
だから今は思い出せないと思いますけどね
だって随分早く死ぬんだからね
大体まあ 8歳  9歳ぐらいになってくると
もう死んでいるんだからね
それからはまあなかなかわからなくなっちゃうんです
小さな子供を見てみると
ものすごく楽しく喜んで
無茶喜んでいる時もあって
虚偽に怒ってものすごいキャーキャーと
もう怒って泣いたり喚いたりする時もあるし
そこで小さな子供同士だったら
まあそういう自分好きな人に対しても同じことで
もうよく見られると思います
だから 昔の素朴な人間も
だいたいそういうふうな
まあ単純な喜怒哀楽というものでね
生きているんだから まあすごくわかりやすいと思いますね
で そこで心というのはそういう働きがあります
で では そうやって感情に心が左右されない場合はどういう人でしょうかと
で 感情に左右されない感情はもう気にしない
人に対する愛着 執着っていうのはもう気にしないということは
違う人間なんですね では
現代の人々はあの人のことを好きということは全くもないんだから
まあそういう感情に振り回されてないと思うかもしれませんが
それは違うんです 現代の方々はただ死んでいるだけのことで
別にどうっていうことじゃないんです
ただ生きてない 元気で明るくて
欲しいもの欲しいと 欲しくないものはそれは欲しくないんだよとかね
そういう単純シンプルで生きてないだけのことで
それですごい感情に振り回されない
すごい人生やってるっていうことじゃないんです
ことで 感情で振り回されない人間っていうのは
かなり強烈な すごいレベル高い精神を持ってる人々なんです
だからお釈迦様がこの第一禅定を説明するんですね
人は心を統一させる 物事から心をもう離れてもらう
愛着っていうのは見るもの聞くものですから
人間であろうとも動物であろうと
それは見るもの 聞くもの
触るものでしょうし そういう眼耳鼻舌身に対する対象から心を離れてもらう
それにはすごいエネルギーは必要なんですよ
だから もともと生命力ない人にとっては
なかなか瞑想なんかはできないんです
すごい強烈に生命力ある人は
あれも欲しい これも欲しいとかね
あいつは嫌だとかいう風に
ものすごいエネルギーが働いてるんです
だから あれこれ欲しい
あれこれ嫌 憎しみというエネルギーをあれちょっと置いておいて
これからその力を離れることにしなさいと
だから 強烈にある活発的なエネルギーを自分が別な方向へ向くんですよ
どういう方向に向くかというと
やっぱりそういうものから離れてやるぞと
だから離れたこと自体もすごい大胆で強烈なんですね
だから 気をつけてほしいところ
何にも無関心やということは
ものすごい危険信号で潰れてるわけじゃないんです
生きてないだけの話で
興味ない 別に興味ない
あれそれ別に興味ないとかね
何にも興味ない もう世の中で何が起きているか全然さっぱりわからない
なんかもう仮面かぶっていろいろかっこつけちゃいますけど
それはもう極端な無知ということなんです
無明なんですよ 毛羽なんです
だから毛羽につなげてくるのは落ち込みと無関心と情動と混乱と
だからまあ偉そうに人がいるんですね
時々私はテレビは見ないんだぞとかね
正邪ぶろうとしてるんですね
言う瞬間で私には感じはそれはお前よりは私の方が優れてるんだよということを言ってるだけの話なんですけど
その言っても私は全然もうゴミ人間のという
全然気にしないんですね
もう考える話し合う必要もないんだと
もうもうとっくに死体やと
もう腐ってるんだと 死体だけだったらもうなんとかいいんだが
これもうもうもうもうウジ虫もついてるんですね
あれこれやと いろんな正邪がいるんですよ
もう腐るほど もしかすると日本の社会はもう正邪でない人っていうのはなかなか稀というかね
私はこの正邪でない人を狙っているんです
悪いこともするはいい加減であれやこれやとか
もう何やるかわからないという元気な連中の場合は
そのエネルギーをいい方向へ変えるということができます
ただ ぼけーっと座って別にそうやってもういる人っていうのは
もう瞑想も何もできません
もうエネルギーがないんですよ
エネルギーが死んだのは無知で死んだ
死ぬんですよ 欲で怒りでエネルギーは死なないんです
もうただ自己破壊にいくだけで
かなり活発的なんですね
欲がある時は結構いろんなことをする
じっとしていられない
欲がある時 怒りがある時でも同じことで
なかなかじっとしていられない
それで欲と無知がね 結びつくと欲があるんだけど
まあということで落ち込んじゃう
欲しいんだけどとかね
そこで落ち込み状態になって引っ込んでしまうんですね
強烈に怒りがある人々も
これ無知とつなげると引っ込むんです
現代社会で見えるのはそういうことで
初めから腰抜けなんです
そこで怒りが入っちゃうと
あるいは欲が入っちゃうと
もう引っ込むんであって
もう役に立たない どれもどんどん死んでしまうんですね
どんどんじゃなくて もうもうすごい速くに死んじゃうんですね
あの人のあの人のことも
あの人のことを好きだと思う男の子が
もうそこで活発だったら
どちらに出て行って どちらの話をつけて
もう別々な日にデートしたりとかね
一生懸命互いにバレないようにとか
いろいろ工夫するんですよ
とにかく活発で動いているんです
そこでバレて女に怒られてすっごくこうやっても
もうこちらすごい元気で機能して
どちらでもやっぱりあまり攻撃しないんですよ
そういうケース見たことはありますけど
どちらの女もとにかく自分の方向に引っ張ってやろうと思っちゃうだけで
あんたは二股かけてとんでもないやつを出ていけとも言わないんです
なぜかと本人がすごい明るいんだから
生き生きしているんだから
やっぱり自分の方が自分が取った方がいいやと思うんですね
だからエネルギーがないんだったら
もう出て行けと思う もう魅力もないということで
すぐ処分されちゃうんです
だから まあ欲怒りはいいということで話ではないんだけど
そこは明るく機能すると
人が活発的であるということだけが必要なんですね
その活発性を正しい方向へ導かなくては
もともとエネルギーがなければ
もうどうにもならんだからね
だから この現代世代の現代時代に見えてくる
このものに無関心とかね
政治にあんまり興味がない
国際状況別に興味がないとか
何にも興味がないんですね
それで私は不思議に思うのは
よくそれで生きてるもんだなと
と不思議でしたけど 後で思い浮かんだこと
やっぱり生きてないんだと
もう死体だと そこで気持ち悪くなっちゃったんですね
人の顔見るのも別に死体
遺体見たら面白いわけじゃないでしょうに
気持ち悪いばっかりではうまくいかないんだから
では ウジ虫が入ってないものと入ってるものという風に区別しようと
じゃあまだまだウジ虫もウミが出てないんだと
ウジ虫が入ってない そこら辺でもう喜び感じられて
ウジ虫が入ってる やっぱりもうもう腐ったからもう置いておきましょうということになってしまっちゃったんですね
だからこの 何でしょうかね
あれにもこれにも何も興味ないということは
勝手作り物じゃなくて
これ強烈に無知が自分を支配して
もうもう行動できないようにしているんです
いい例えがないんですけど
例えばこの大型の太陽なんかは強烈にエネルギー出してますよ
ものすごい強烈に やがてこの大型な太陽っていうのはブラックホールになるんですよ
ブラックホールになってきちゃうと
存在するかもわからなくなっちゃうんです
何も発生しません 電波だとしても
科学者がなんとかここら辺ブラックホールなんかあるわよと思うのは
これ推測でなんですよ
ほとんど たまにブラックホールもある時代になってくると
物事を吸収して吸収して吸収して
もうほとんど満杯状態になってくると
ガンマ線やら色々線微妙出し始めるんです
そうするとそこでだけで
まあまあこれぐらいの大きさのものがあるんだぞとかね
なんとか分かりますけど
もうそろそろブラックホールの寿命にもなってるんですね
あと何万年たっちゃうと
これはまた爆破するという
まあそういうことで 人間っていうのはもうエネルギーを出してる間はなんとかまあ管理できますけど
逆になっちゃうとどうにもならないんです
だからブラックホールだったら近寄らない方がいいんですよ
近寄っちゃうと自分も分解してしまって
それうしになってしまって
さっともう吸い込まれるだけで
こちらまで破壊になっちゃうんです
だからこの無気力で無機能で無関心で
私も無関心ですよ 何にしたって
全然気にしない 気にしないんだからと言って行動的じゃないわけじゃないんです
何かやろうとしたら何かごちゃごちゃ文句言って
ああそう じゃあやめたと
全然もうそういう無関心なんです
無意味なことでもやりましょうと
じゃあやりましょうと
私はしっかりやる 他の人は中途半端でやる
それそういうことなんです
しっかりやったんだから
何の一欠けらもそちらに執着も関心もあるわけじゃないんです
だからエネルギーはそういう風に変えなくちゃいけないんです
だからさ エネルギーは持ってないともう育てることはできない
ブラックホールになってしまっちゃうと
皆様は現代科学的なことを私より知ってるですから
ブラックホールというところは光まで吸収するんですよ
吸収するということは
例えば人間 ブラックホールのそばに行ったら
人間がパチンと磁石のように吸い込まれる意味じゃないんです
分解するんですよ あまりにもエネルギーの恐ろしさに
幻想に分解するわけじゃないんです
分子が 素粒子にまで分解するんです
消えちゃうんです だからこちらの存在までなくなっちゃうんです
だからこの これから死体って失礼だから
生きているブラックホールやと
もう命名しようか ブラックホールやと
だから人間もそうやって無知だけで旗を立てて
無知で生きるともう生きているブラックホールなんですよ
だから周りの人々のエネルギーをギューッと吸収しちゃって
もう消えてしまうだけ
人のエネルギーを吸収して自分が明るくなるんだったら
それはありがたい話で
相手のエネルギーはなくなっちゃって
この人はさらにエネルギーがなくなる状態になるという
無知の力っていうのはそういうことだから
すごく危ないんですね
無知と繋げるのは行動力はない
もう何か頼むためには必死で頼まなくちゃいけないし
頼んでやってもどうでもいいというね
そこで本人がもうやっと苦労してやったんだからね
こちらにしてみれば たった二
三分の仕事かもしれない
向こうは 1週間もかかったと
そこで無茶褒めてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
見ただけでもうこんなのはゴミだという風に捨てたいんですけどね
だからそういう風な人間っていうのは
世の中にはいくらでもいるんだからね
自分だけ勝手に不幸になるんじゃなくて
周りの人の明るさまで全部消しちゃうんですね
その光も吸収しちゃうんです
人の光を消したら自分が光れと
それもできない だから借金して贅沢する人の程もないんですよ
いるでしょうに 借金して贅沢やっちゃって
それから全部パーになっちゃうとかね
それでもなんかどこかで可愛いんですよ
生きてるんだから だから悪人以上にはひどいんですよ
この無関心 無気力っていうのは
立ち直りできませんし
悪人だったら更生できる
別に何か悪いことをやったこともないんだから
この人々はもう行動的じゃない
何も行動を起こしたこともないんだから
更生っていうのは言葉も当てはまらないんですよ
まあ悪いことばかりしか頭に考えていない人だったら捕まって
強引にてめえ更生してやるぞっていうのはできますよ
いいことっていうのをやった覚えもないんだという極悪人でも更生できますよ
でも無記録だったらもう更生という言葉さえも当てはまらない
別になんで更生させられなくちゃいけないんだ
私は何かやったのと 私は何かやったんですかねという調子ですからね
だから訴えられませんでしょ
だからアンヌリマーラという人がもう九百九十九人も人を殺しちゃったんですよ
活発なんですよ 先生にもお前人をもうあの千人の人をちゃんと神様の中に生贄にせなくちゃいけないんだと
卒業を通してはと ああ
そう ではやるぞと えらい活発なんですね
やってることっていうのはとんでもない悪なんですけど
だからお釈迦様にほんのちょっと喋っただけで更生することができたんですよ
無記録だったらもうブラックホールです
近寄らない方がいい はい
まあそれがもう無知で
無知と一緒に繋げる煩悩っていうのは
この貪瞋睡眠上光と疑ですね
全部もうエネルギーはなくなるものばっかりで
欲と繋げるのは まあロボディッティ何だったっけな
ロボディッティマーナ
ロボとディッティとマーナという三つですけど
ロボは欲でディッティっていうのはいろいろ展開ですね
マーナっていうのは慢ですね
高慢やらね どちら見ても活発なんですよ
俺が偉そうと思うことでも
結構機能行動的だからね
怒りと繋げるのはイッサマッチレボッカですからね
で もう嫉妬とかね 物惜しみとか後悔とかね
どちら見てもどこかで行動的なんです
すっごい悪いもんなんですけど
一応行動的 はい うん そういうことだから
このまあ欲があるから憎しみがあるかと
欲がある人は欲から欲が生まれるは
欲から憎しみが生まれるは
怒りがある憎しみがある人の場合は
憎しみから欲が生まれるは
愛着が生まれるは 憎しみから憎しみが生まれる
ものすごいもうもう戦争みたいな頭の中でものすごいもう行動を起こしてるんですね
荒波を受けてるんですね
その人の場合は更生する余地があります
もう最悪の状態にいるんだからね
この人は 愛着があって
さらにさらに愛着が生まれていくわ
あるいは愛着があって
どんどんもう憎しみが生まれていくわとかね
もうじっとしないんですね
とにかく それがすごいとんでもない悪い状態で
その人には更生が効くんです
では 愛着に左右されない
振り回されない 憎しみに振り回されないならば
どういうことかというと
その人はそういう対象からもう離れてやるぞと
欲から離れてみる 離れて心を落ち着けてやるぞと
集中させてやるぞと あの強烈なエネルギーを集中力ということになっちゃうんですね
それには何か瞑想とかしなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると心は統一する
統一したんですけど すごいエネルギーなんですよ
そうすると初めてもう愛着も憎しみからも心は振り回されないようになる
スッカジェーカというのはそういうことなんです
で ヴィヴィッチェヴァカーメヒ
欲から離れて ヴィヴィッチャプセレヒダンメヒ
不善からも離れて サヴィタッカンサヴィターランというのは
この言葉をかけて瞑想することなんですね
で ちゃんと何か言葉をかけて瞑想することによって
ヴィーヴェーカジャン
欲から離れて離れたんだから生まれたピーディス感
清涼感を味わうんです
すごい清涼感を味わう
それはパタマンジャーナ
第一禅定と言うんだと
それに入るともう感情に振り回されない
感情を排除しちゃったんです
憎しみも怒りも 憎しみも怒りも排除したんですけど
すごい強烈にエネルギーも
何て言いますか コンセントレーションという
もうすっと固めたんですね
だから 俗世間で活発な
ものすごい抜群に活発な人と第二禅定に入ってる人を比べて比べないほど
第一禅定の人がすごい活発なんです
ものすごいエネルギーを持ってる
俗世間で一日もう二 三時間も寝ないでものすごい仕事をしながら
あらゆる商売に手を出して
いろんなことをやってるんだって言ったら
すごい元気 エネルギー一丁で凄いと感じるでしょうね
それとは比べないほど
第二禅定に入った人の方がものすごいエネルギーなんです
しかし そのエネルギーは欲から離れることから得たんです
その人にとってはヨッピッセペーマードーソージャーリソーピッセタスニサミーノホイッティ
愛着から怒りが生まれるならば
これはその人に対してはありませんと
愛着から 一行余計に増えてますね
増えてるか間違ってるか
この一行目がヨーピッサペーマー
ペーマー ペーモージャーエティソーピッサタスミンサメイノホティでないと
次はヨーピッサペーマードーソージャーエティソーピッサタスミンサメイノホティなんですね
だからこのページの一番下の一行は単語間違ってると思います
ペーマーペーモージャーエティなんですね
ペーマンジャーエティ
ペーモーではない それでペーマードーソージャーエティソーピッサタスミンサメイ
愛着から怒りが生まれるならば
それもないし ヨーピッサドーサーペーマンジャーエティ怒りから愛着が生まれるならばそれもないし
怒りから怒りが生まれるのならばそれもないという四つですね
それで次に第二番目の禅定の説明が入るんですね
その人はものすごいエネルギーあるんだから
第一禅定に入ったんだから
第二禅定も作ってみる
その時は頭から言葉もなくなっちゃうんですね
思考もなくなって さらに統一する
本格的なサマーディが生まれてくる
第一禅定っていうのは統一だけでサマーディとは言わない
第二禅定はサマーディなんです
なぜかというと もう思考も機能しないんです
その時は それの時 その人も感情に振り回されることはない
それから第三番目の禅定が
で この喜び消す感もなくなっちゃうんですね
なくなっちゃって平安な心を作るというね
いわゆる肉体的 一応喜びは種類ですから
その種類書いてます 四番目に入ると二種類の喜びもなくなって
もうただ平安な気持ちだけでいられる
言葉もないし 次にヤスミン・ビッカヴェーサマエー
下から三番目の段落なんですね
二ページ目の
ヤスミン・ビッカヴェーサマエービクアサバーナンカヤーアナアサワンチェトーイムッティンパンニャービムッティンディッテワダンメーサヤンアビンニャーサッチカッターウプサンパッジャビヘレティ
ある時はビクはアサバーナンカヤ
煩悩をなくしてアナアサワン
無漏の煩悩のないチェトーイムッティン
心を解脱させるパンニャービムッティン
智慧でもって解脱をする
心を開放するということは禅定に入ることなんです
で パンニャービムッティンっていうのは完全たる悟りのこと
智慧で煩悩をなくすことなんですね
両方埋めてディッテワダンメー
この世で今世でサヤンアビンニャー
自分でよく智慧でもってサッチカッターを経験してウプサンパッジャビヘレティ
それに入っていると いわゆる煩悩をなくすと完全に
解脱をすると だから心を完全に解脱するっていうこと
またすごいエネルギーが必要必要とするものなんです
それが一番エネルギーが必要なんですよ
ちっぽけな活発性で できません
人間持ってる生命の儀はもうもう頂点に達したところで
智慧があれば解脱を得られるんです
その人にはペーマーペーマンジャーエティ
愛着から愛着が生まれるというならば
パンピッサパヒーナンホーティ
もうなくなっているんだと
前の禅定の場合はナホーティもうありませんと
怒りませんだけの話で
悟ったならばもうなくなりましたと
怒りませんではなくて
だから言葉の使い方は違うんですよ
下から番目の段落のちょっと上の行を見ると
ヨーピッサペーマードーソージャーエティ
ソーピッサタスミンサメイナホーティ
ナホーティ ありませんという文章なんですね
下から番目の段落で出てくるのはパヒーナンホーティ
もうなくしましたと ありませんではなくて
愛着から愛着が生まれる状態はもうなくしました
壊しました 滅しました
だからもう現れる恐れもないんです
ウッチンネムーラ 根元からもう根こそぎに取り出したと
ターラワットカタ もうターラ木のように
もう倒してしまったと
ターラキっていうのは倒しちゃうとまた復活とはしない
ターラっていうのはこのヤシなんですね
ヤシの場合はこの上のところをほんのちょっといじっちゃうとも
そのだけで巨大なヤシの木であろうとも
まあ殺すのは簡単です
ちょっと風で倒れてももう復活はしない場合もあるし
あるいは一番上の方 どんな木であろうとも
葉っぱが出るところ すごい柔らかいんですけどね
そこら辺ちょっと取ってしまえば
もうそれで死んじゃうんです
植物の中で このヤシ科の植物っていうのはそういう面白いんですね
もう枝は出てこないし
たった個の細胞の種しかないんですね
上へ上へ行くために かなり大木もありますよ
だからそこを例えばタラワットカタンアナバハヴァカタン
また生まれないことにしましたと
アイティンアヌッパダダンマ
もう二度と現れることのないと
もう強烈に強調するんですよ
パヒーナンホーティで十分なんですけど
消しましたよと 滅しましたよと
でもそれで十分じゃない
もう根こそぎに取りましたよと
もうもうターラ木のようにしてしまったよと
アナバハヴァカタン 生まれないようにしましたと
アイティンアヌッパダダンマ
もう二度と再生しないようにしましたよと
だから悟ったならば この煩悩はもう二度と再生しない
どう踏ん張ってもできない状態にしてしまうんですね
それでペーマードーソージャーエティ
欲情 愛着から怒りが生まれるといえば
ソーピッサパヒーナンホーティ
それもなくなりましたと
根こそぎにしたんだと
ヤンピッサドーサペマンジャーエティ
怒りから愛着が生まれるというならば
それももうまるっきりないようにしてしまった
で ヨーピッサドーサドーソージャーエティ
憎しみから憎しみが生まれる状態は
それももう二度と生まれないように
再現できないように もう根こそぎに取り除いて
もう滅してしまったと
それで悟りの境地で終了するんです
だから ごく一般的な教育も知識もない
ごく普通の感情で農業をやって
何か仕事をしている人々に悟りまで語れるんです
その人々は あれは喜怒哀楽
感情で日々ものすごい興奮状態で混乱状態で生き生きしているんだから
そこからそのエネルギーをいい方向へ
こういう風に持っていくんだよと
だから普通すごい生命エネルギーを持ってる人なら推測できますよ
禅定に入ったらすごいエネルギーでしょうということはね
ものすごいいいでしょう
これよりはと こんなにも愛着
憎しみばっかしで もう毎日もうガチャガチャガチャガチャやってるよりは
これから離れた方がものすごいもっと清らかなエネルギーになるんじゃないかなと
もっと楽しくなるんじゃないかなというと
そういう人よりだったら推測できますよ
だからそういう人なら頑張っちゃうんです
そこで悟った人に対して
お釈迦様はいくつかの専門用語を使ってるんです
下から番目の段落 これからただ
この仏教のいろいろ専門用語ではあまり使わない専門用語なんですけど
一般の世界で 当時のインド社会で使っていた単語やと思います
アヤンウッチティビクビクネブッセンティナッパティセンナッパティセーネティネドゥーパヤニネドゥーパヤティネパッジャラティネアッパッジャヤティ
ドゥーパジェニーかな
どちらかわからない で
ウッセンティ その人にはウス
ウッセーネーティ ウッセーネーティってはしない人だというんだと
ナッパティセーネーティ
アッパティセーナと言うんだと
ね ドゥーパイニ ドゥーパイニではないというんだよと
パッジャラティと言わないんだと
アッパッジャラティとも言うんだよと
はぁ これは意味はウッセーネーティっていうのは
えーとなんでしたっけね
私もこの原始世界でしかたとえ出てもないんですけど
このシロアリとかはこの必ずしもこの家にいるわけじゃなくて
外に住んでるんですよ
シロアリはちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこちょことアリ塚作るんですよ
アリ塚っていうのはアリが作るものじゃないんです
面白いことシロアリが作るんです
シロアリの塚っていうのはアリ塚じゃなくてシロアリ塚なんですけど
巨大に大きく作るんです
アフリカなんかだったら
かなり上までもう四メートル
八メートルまでドーンと作るんですよ
塔みたいに で 下も結構もうかなり面積取っちゃうんです
で ウッサラっていうのは
このシロアリが住んでるところはどんどんどんどんこうやっても上に上に増えていくんですね
で 私たちの場合でも どこかアパートを借りて一年ぐらいいると
もうすごい荷物増えてるでしょうに
三年 五年いて引っ越ししようとしたら
もう引っ越しもできないぐらい
アパートに来たのはただカバン二つだけでアパートに来たんですけど
引っ越しするときは大型のトラック一台必須になるというふうな感じになりますね
だからそこはウッサラ方式
方式なんですね  堆積ですか
うん？堆積するって まあまあ極普通
いつでもそういうことになります
この建物にしても 入った時よりは今ものすごい大量にあのゴミがあるんです
大量 いらんものに あと半年経つと
いらんものしかないってことになるでしょうと思います
だからそれはウッサラ
堆積する生き方 だからこのサドッタイ人としてはもう堆積者やと言えないんだと
アッパティセーナ うーんと
これは普通の一般の学者がね
まあ調べない そうたくさん出てくる単語ですけどもね
お釈迦様定義しますから
今別に困らなくても それからお釈迦様の定義は出てきますけど
アッパティセーナ それでも難しい
堆積という言葉の反対かもしれませんと思っても
うんうん これは対抗することなんですね
積み重ねるではなくて
堆積するんじゃなくて
他のものに対してこちらから対抗していくという
対抗性ですね だから機能的に反対です
だから堆積性だったら物は溜まるでしょうし
対抗性だ ものはぶん投げるでしょうし
どちらかというと堆積することの反対なんですね
例えば平和な時は 我々はいろんなものは育てて育てて
作って作って作って堆積する
周りに敵が出てくると
それに合わせていろんなものを作ってはぶん投げる
こちらはそのところではなくなっていきますけどね
で 周りの敵が出てきて攻撃も仕掛けてくると
こちらもさっさとそういうものを作って攻撃をすると
ということで 平和な時代では軍事力は何もなかったんですけど
もう周りは敵が出てくるとどんどん軍事力が増えてきて
いろんなものを開発したりして
そこで対抗するというね
そういう状態も心にないんだと
ドゥーパーヤーニっていうのは煙が立たないということです
パッジャラティっていうのはもう燃えているというか
光り出しているというね
燃えている状態 アッパジャエテっていうのは燃えてから出てくる状態なんですね
轟々と燃えている状態と
火が消えた時もまた轟々と焼き出してますね
それはアッパジャエテという状態
どちらにも入れませんね
覚った人は だからその単語で一般の人の生き方説明しているんです
しかし あんまりよくそっちを使える仏教用語ではないので
辞書に意味は書かないし
分かってないし 仏教をわかってないんだからね
特に仏教学者はね ですから
この思惟体やら発想等やら
もうそういう専門用語なら知ってるんであって
それ以外は知らない そこでそちらのサンシット語は何なのかと調べて英訳しようとするんですけど
英訳したら日本訳もありますけど
英訳なかったら日本訳もないし
でもサンシット語から取っている単語でもないんです
ほとんど日常生活で使っている単語から使うんだから
お釈迦様がね だからサンシット語もそんなに大量にあるわけじゃないし
ブッダの時代でそんなサンシット語っていうものはあったわけでもないしね
では お釈迦様の定義を理解すればわかると思います
カタンチャ ビッケ ビックウ ビックウッセーネーティ
ッセーネーティっていうことはどういう意味でしょうかと
イダ
ビッカヴェ ビックゥ ルーパン アッタトー サムヌパッサティ ルーパワンタンワー アッタナーン アッタニワー
ルーパン ルーパス ミン ミーワー アッタナーン
で これで色受想行識という五蘊あります
五蘊っていうのは自分の体のこと
自分のこと 人間自分っていうのは肉体の自分と言うんですけど
仏教では肉体だけじゃなくてね
感覚 思考 生命としてのエネルギーもいろいろ一寸ありますからね
心 そういう一寸で自分というものはできているんだと
だからちょっと現代知識の方々には
あと1万年 2万年発展しない限りは
研究はね そこら辺は発展できないでしょうと思いますけど
当時では一応ブッダだけですよ
それも お釈迦様からちょこちょことパクったことはありますけど
ヒンドゥー教でウパニシャッドでは
でも完全に理解していないんです
だから自分というのは
生命というのは色受想行識という五寸でできてますね
色というのは肉体 物体的な身体
受というのは感覚 それからサンニャーっていうのは概念
あれこれと概念を作ること
ルーパ サンニャー サンカーラ
サンカーラっていうのは一応エモーショナルなエネルギーなんですね
だから怒りやら憎しみやら
とにかく次の行動に人を押すエネルギーなんですね
サンカーラは それからヴィンヤーナ
認識すること だから受想行識は一緒にワンセットで行動するんですね
何か感じちゃうと身体で瞬間に概念も生まれていますよ
それから感情も生まれています
それは欲しいか欲しくないかとかね
その感情によって感情が次の行動のエネルギーになるんですね
だから感情はサンカーラと行と言うんですね
何か体に触れて触れたところで痛いと感じたら
嫌ということを感情が瞬時に一緒に生まれるんですね
嫌だったらもう離れなくちゃいけない
だから次の行動 離れるぞという次の行動を起こすんですね
離れるぞと次の行動を起こすために怒りということが起きたんですね
それをサンカーラと言うんです
だから常に我々は瞬間たりともその五蘊から離れることはないんです
だから自分というのはそんなもんです
認識することがなくなっちゃうと人が死んでるんだから
全て認識することからスタートするんです
認識してから感覚が生まれたわけじゃなくて
感覚が認識するんだからね
同時なんですね 一緒なんですね
それが自分というもの
ルーパーナサンニャサンカーラ
ヴィンヤーナ それをわかってない人々は魂があるんだ
魂があるんだ 俺がいるんだと
いつでも我があるというとてつもない妄想概念で生きてるんです
何も調べてないんです
科学的に厳密に自分を厳密に分解してないんです
できない 人間は考えるのはもう肉体があって魂がある
それだけ 何が魂かと知らないし
だったら肉体以外のもの
全て魂にならなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そんなことも知らないし
だからお釈迦様は人間のこの愚かさ知ってるんだから
まるっきり非科学的で
もう感情で迷信で もう神話しか信じない人間だから
あてにならな お釈迦様はそこはすっごくうまく使って人々を茶化しちゃうんですよ
だからこの人間には魂があり人と出てきたら
他は何があるんだ 体があり
魂があると ある人が実際に体があるんじゃないかと
体をすべて支配して体にもの言ってやってるんではないかと言ったんですね
言ったら君体が魂として見ているんではないかと
そうだろうと それ具体的な話でしょうと
何したっても体が大事ですよと
肉体が大事ですよと 肉体が支えて土台で全てのものを動かさせているんではないかと
わからないのかと ブッダにそれぐらいのことはと
その具体的な話 あなたは具体的じゃないんだと
目の前にある肉体のことは否定してるんではないかと
無常やとか無我やとかに
お釈迦様は全然持ちすぎてということは
君が肉体が魂やと思ってるんでしょうに
そうです では聞きますけど
この肉体は変わらないのかと
年取ったり衰えたりしないのかと
壊れたりしないのかと
死んだりはしないのかと
と言いたいんですから
それはまあ死にますよと
ということは 君が言ってるのは無常たるものが魂であるってことでしょ
君が肉体が無常だと知ってますけど
だから君言ってるのは無常たるものは魂であるという
無常じゃないかと 無常であるってことは具体的ではないかと
そこにいえ 肉体は壊れても人の感覚どうしますかということで考えたり
いろいろずっとやってますよと
人一つでは君の感覚は何なのかと
君の思考って何なのかと
ずっと永遠不滅で変化しないのかと
君の認識認識っていうのは何なのかと
ずっと同じことしか認識してないのかと
全て無常ですよと 無常たるものは魂というバカがいるのかと
いうことで終わっちゃうんです
だからこのみんなこの肉体と魂があるんだっていう風になってくるんですけど
そこはアホやっていうこともお釈迦様知ってるんだから
そこら辺すごい茶化しちゃって
もうバカにして見せるんです
だから無常やと もう我がないんだと
いい加減しなさいという話になります
そういうことだから 仏教ではいつでも私っていう場合はルーパーナサンニャサンカーラヴィンヤーナという 5つで五蘊で言うんですね
色受想行識という五蘊にしているんです
だから五蘊に分けたことはブッダが初めて五蘊に分けたんであって
あの すごい研究なさってる学者の方々が言ってるように
これは偉大なるヒンドゥー教からパクったわけでも盗んだわけでもないんです
ヒンドゥー教のテキストには出てこないんです
単語は出てくるんですけど
こういう風に四相対比としてしっかりと自分を
生命を一筋に分解するということはないんです
分解したならば その時点で我論が消えるはずなんですけどね
だからブッダはもう無我論って実体ないってことは一貫しているんですけど
それで第二の結句になってくると
もう無我と言ったんですけど
非我と言ってないんだと
逆です 非我と言って 無我とは言ってない
無我と言ってるんですけど
いや ですからあの 非我
非我が正しくて 無我は間違ってる
阿比達磨の考え方だって
中村元先生  じゃあ無我は間違いだっていいの？ と日本の学者は言う人もいます
これアナッタはどうやって日本語訳するんですかね
非我って訳した方が正しいって
他に非ずと  だから 五蘊は我じゃないって言ってるだけで
我がないって言ってるわけじゃないっていう
うんうん あのラーダ・クリシュナンさんの考え方なんですけど
ラーダ・クリシュナンのテキストでそう書いたところで
本を書いた時点でアンタ間違ってるんだよと他の学者がいっぱいいましたけどね
そこは聞かない こちらでは
ラーダ・クリシュナンももうちょっと古代の学者で
現代仏教学者ではなくて
もうとっくに死んでるし
インドの大統領でしたけどもね
初めの大統領 学者ですけどね
サルファリ・ラーダ・クリシュナンという哲学者です
すごい本いろいろ書いてます
インド人として政治家としてものすごい立派な人でね
もう単なる気持ち悪い政治家というわけじゃないんですよ
ものすごい学者で もう大変研究論文書いたり
それでついでにインドの面倒を見てやると
金もうけをっていうことはないんです
だからインドはもう結構その次元では結構落ち着いて
ずっと守られてはきたんですけどね
はい まあその人の考え方ですけど
もう我はあるんだと で
ブッダはもう五蘊は無我と言っただけですと
それっていうのはものすごい主観で
自分の好みで物事をねじ曲げるだけ
お釈迦様は聞くのは この五蘊以外に何があるのかと
人間に認識できるのは五蘊だけだから
それもやっとですからね
だから認識のできんものもあると言えないでしょうに
五蘊 我は五蘊以外にあるんだよと言っちゃえば簡単でしょうに
なんで言ってないんですかね
無我は我に非ず 真我が別にあると言っちゃえば簡単でしょうに
お釈迦様ってそれぐらい日本語
パーリ語分からなかったでしょうね
子供みたいに それ言いたいんですね
結局は もし五蘊以外我があれば言っちゃえばいいでしょうに
いろんな経典でお釈迦様がこの
この塵一粒我に取るならばね
取れるものあるならば言いますよと
塵一粒ぐらいでも だからこの
悟りにはものすごいこれ猛毒で
我っていうのは執着 イコール執着だからね
我イコール意味だから
我イコール尊いものだからね
我イコール真理であって
本当のことであって 大事なものであって
価値があるものでしょうに
ということ執着でしょうに
解脱とか合わないんです
だから極端な邪見で我にするんです
間違いの中でももうたちの悪い
一番たちが悪い邪見は我なんですね
それを堂々ともう学者が言うんだからね
もう これでブッダに対して公平な研究出てくるっていうことはもうありえないんですが
そんな困ることはないんですけどね
しっかり研究する方々もいるんだから
いるしね それでこの人間っていうのは
自分の体に対して 五蘊に対して
まあ例えば単純数学で考えたっても
自分イコール五蘊イコール非我と言えば
どこに我があるんで そうすると
我があったら自分の中になんとかの形になっちゃあかんでしょうに
我は自分にはまるっきり関係なかったら関係ないんだからね
梵我一如 なんとかな こりゃことにならんだからね
初めから我っていうのは自分のものでなければあかんしね
それで自分イコール五蘊で五蘊イコール非我であるならばね
結論は無我っていうことでしょうに
はい それで比丘 人がルーパがあったとサマノパッサティ
自分の肉体は我としてサマノパッサティ
考える サマノパッサティっていうのは合意に考えることなんですよ
そのまま見えるんだったらもう別なパッサティでいいんですけど
だから妄想するっていうことですね
思考する 肉体は我であると
ルーパワンタンワーッタナ
あるいは我にも形があるんだよと
魂にも体がありますよと
いわゆる体が魂か 自分の魂が体の形をとっているのか
どちらかというんですね
あるいはアッタにはルーパン
魂があって 魂の中に体が入り込んでいる
魂があって 魂の中に魂が巨大なもので
親分で その親分の中に肉体が入り込んでいる
あるいはルーパスミンアッターナ
逆に肉体が物質的な肉体があって
この肉体の中に魂が入って住んでいるんだと
それどちらか考えちゃうんだよと
だからその文章で一切の我を否定してますよ
文章をちょっと読んでみれば
全然学者っていう人はそういうふうに
なんで分析してみないのかってわからないんですね
その単語っていうのは
単なる繰り返し文句でもなく
これすごい大事な文句だから
ずっと繰り返しで出てくるんですよ
暗記しておけと そこで当時のインド人の思考と哲学と宗教と比較してみると
もう見事にそういう人々はいたんですよ
いたんだから もう論理で過ごすっていうんですよ
エクスクルーシブということでも漏れないように
そこで我と肉体と我の関係で
それだけでも絶対我は存在しないということになるんですよ
たった一行目だけでも
肉体がある 肉体が魂一つ
あるいは魂の中に肉体が入り込んでいる
あるいは肉体の中に魂が入り込んでいる
それ四つのステージなんですね
学者いうのは肉体が魂ではないとブッダが言っただけですよ
それだけじゃないんですよ
肉体の中に入っているわけでもないし
肉体が魂の中に入っているわけでもないんだよと
それ時点でもう魂はまるっきり否定されますよ
だって 我々にとっては肉体があることは確かでしょうし
だからどこに魂があるのかと調べなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それになってくると 肉体が魂のでもないし
肉体の中に魂があるわけでもないし
魂の中に肉体があるわけでもないんです
で 四行目で魂が肉体の形をとっているわけでもないんです
だから あなたの形は魂の形だよという人々もいるし
あるいはあなたの魂はあなたの形をとってますよと
だからいろいろありますよ
人がすごく嫌な性格とかでも
肉体は魂がその形をとっちゃいますよと
あるいはもともと魂の形の通りに肉体が動いているんだよと
私にはもうその一行だけでも
魂の完全否定にはなりますけど
そのお釈迦様はどうにも持っていくんだから
すべては完全無我であるということは
もう何万回も言ったことになりますけど
それからこの感覚に対しても感覚が
魂か 魂は感覚の形をとっているか
感覚の中に魂あるか 魂の中に感覚があるかっていう風に人間はいろいろ妄想するんだと
それからサンニャー概念
それからサンカーラ 衝動的なエネルギー
それから認知機能 だからその五蘊の中にもないし
五蘊の外にもないというんだからね
それでも我があるんだよというのはどういう理屈かはわからない
それがウスセーネーティというんで堆積するんだと
だから私がいるんだ 私がいるんだ
魂があるんだということによって
人間があれこれやと堆積していくんです
感情も煩悩も欲も悪もなんだかんだでも
だから苦しみの原因はこの我をあると妄想することなんです
幻覚作ることはこれ幻覚なんですね
魂があると思っちゃうと
大事だ 執着しなくちゃと
捨てがたいんだと だからすごい欲張って高慢のために見栄張るために
金儲けるために 自分の社会的な立場を作るために研究する方々にとっては
もうジリジリともう執着あるんだからもう言いたくないんですね
言ってもいいのに 別に研究だから
ブッダがそう言っても
俺は信じませんよって言っちゃえば
それで物は通じるんだからね
だって カトリック教の神父さんにでも僕でも研究できるんだから
ブッダがそう言ってる
しかし私は神様を信じている
それでいいでしょうに
ブッダが間違ってるやなんとかという言う権利はないでしょうに
そういうことでこの堆積する
だから私に大事な魂があるということになってくると
我々は執着的になっちゃうんですね
もう離れ難くなっちゃって
全部集まることになっちゃうんです
何が集まるかというと
業ばっかり集めて もうそれでもう永遠に輪廻転生する
苦しみがずっと続いてしまうんですね
だからもう無我に達したんだから
何にも執着しない 全部壊してしまったんですね
悟った人は だからウスサではない
堆積性はないと そこで次の言葉
パティセーナという言葉
攻撃性ですね カタンチャ ビッケービックー パティッセーネーティ
イダ ビッケービックー アッコーサンタン パッチャッコーサンティ
アッコーサンタンというのはこの悪口言う人ですね
コラとかこの野郎とか何とか失礼な言葉かける人に対してパッチャッコーサンティ言い返す
相手が怒るでしょうに
怒って何か言葉言うでしょうに
こちらも言い返す それが攻撃型なんですね
ローサンタンナン パティローセンティ
ローセンティというのはすごい侮辱的な言葉言って侮辱することなんですね
侮辱されると逆に侮辱する
とにかく自然に心の中にその感情が生まれるんですよ
向こうは悪口を言うと
こちらでも悪口の言葉が生まれてくる
新しく 今までなかったんですけどね
人が自分を侮辱すると
自分が全然人を侮辱する気持じゃなかったんですよ
でもなんか関係もないのに
相手が自分を侮辱してて
こちらもじゃあ侮辱してやるぞという気持ちが生まれてくる
いわゆる向こう敵に対して
そうで新たに攻撃体制が現れてくる
それは悟った人にはないんです
堆積することもない あれも欲しい
これもやりましょう これもやりますとかね
それもないし じゃあこういう風に攻撃しようということも出てこない
心は落ち着いている だから攻撃型の心は感情に振り回される人
怒りから怒り生まれる
怒りから欲が生まれる
欲から怒りが生まれる
欲から欲が生まれる 人間にとっての場合はやっぱりずっと生まれてくるんですよ
攻撃してやるぞとかね
それはパティセーナの人が
悟った人にとってはそれがない
次にドゥーパーヤティという煙出すこと
こんなのは難しいんだからね
もう瞑想でもした経験があればなんとか説明できるんだけど
難しいですね ドゥーパーヤティということは
一応わかりやすい言葉では妄想するってことなんです
アスミーティ ビッケーウェー サティ イッタスミーティ ホーティ
アスミー 私がいると 我がありきという前提がある場合は
じゃあこの世にいるんだぞと
私はこういうものだよという妄想が生まれてくるんです
だから妄想が生まれるために
まず前提としての妄想が必要なんです
それは我があるという妄想なんですね
それは幻覚なんですね
自然に人間にあるんです
偉大な哲学者に発見されなくても
大体生命たるものには我がいるという前提があるんです
その我がいるという前提の妄想が
私はこういうものであると
イッタスミという妄想が作るんですね
このようにイッタスミ
エワン この世である アンジャタスミ
これは違うと これは本来の私ではありませんと
本来の私は別だよという感じもある
アサスミ うーん ミャンマー本
微妙に単語を変えても
時々ミャンマー版の場合
パーリ語はすごい派手に間違ってるんですけど
ブッダが言いたかった意味がそれてない時もありますし
スリランカ版の場合は言語学的にパーリ語だけ完成してやるぞというぐらいのこともありますから
うーん アサスミどこだ
昔私は学生の時代では分析したことありますけど
アサスミなんて まあ微妙な差なんですけど
私がいる 私は例えば自分の状態にいる
私はこのもの この通りであるというふうに思うこと
あるいはもうエワン エワンっていうのはだいたい同義語で
日本訳は難しいんですけど
過去の如くエワンというのは過去の如く私がいるということで
アンジャタっていうのは
本当は本当の私は違うんだよという思うことで
アサスミっていうのは今の状態じゃないんだと
私は 今は本物じゃないんだという
サタスミ サットアスミ
まあサッっていうのはもうサッということで
この実体として何か今
今 幻覚も本物の自我ではないかもしれませんだけど
実体として本物の自分がどこか隠れているんだよということで
サンティっていうのはいるっていうことで
イッタンサンティ このように別な単語を使ってますね
エワンサンティ アンジャターサンティ
あるいはホーティって動詞使って
ホーティ アピヘサンティ
アピーッタンサンティ
アピエワンサンティ アピアニャターサンティ
バビッサンティ 将来ですね
このようになるでしょうと
あるいは違うようになるでしょうと
いうふうにいろいろ考える
まあごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ自分に対してずっと妄想することなんです
だから妄想する形はこちらで微妙な言語で分析していますけど
これはもうパーリ語ではそういう風な
もうドイツ語でもできますけどね
このきめ細かい分析できますけど
もう他の言語ではね そんな優れてないんだから難しいんです
微妙に数学的に動詞を変えて変えて意味を変えるっていうことはね
で 日本語を聴くともう相当考えることもできないので難しい
だからこの だから単純でよろしいと思いますよ
どうせ人間のことだからね
自分がいるということがあるんだから
我々はただまあ時々にこれは本物の自分じゃないよとかね
時々私はこういうものやとかね
どちらでも思っちゃうでしょうね
私は本来は怠け者じゃないと
と言いつつも 本物の自分というのは本当は怠け者じゃなくて
もっと別なものではないかとかね
何か考えちゃう あるいは私は本物は怠け者で
これ嫌だ 別な自分になりたいとかね
そういう風にいろんな妄想が生まれている
あるいは私は今はこんなもんですけど
将来はもっといい人間になるんじゃないかなとかね
あるいは将来はこういう自分になってる方がいいとかね
で いろいろ自分ということについて考えちゃうんですね
その妄想っていうのはものすごい強烈なもので
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやってみると
まずこういう世界にぶつかりますよ
この自分自分というね
で そこで自分がこういうものであるということを考えて瞑想変えるんですよ
ヴィパッサナーやらないんです
だからやってもやっても
私が言う通りにやらない限りは
もう悟りなんかはもうまるっとありえない
もう逆 度逆 言っても言っても
こいつにも教えてやるぞという気分になっちゃって
自分のやり方でやるんです
だからそこはなんでそうなるのかというと
これは私がいるという実感がそうさせるんですよ
それは人を貶したっても怒鳴ったっても意味がないんです
生命にはそれがあるんです
私がいるという 例えば
もう普通は眠気は瞑想すると出てごめんなさいだけど
眠気が出て もうそれで考えちゃうでしょうに
色々これは睡眠不足だと思いますけどとか言うんですね
それはその人の妄想の世界なの
だから それでどういう理屈かというと
本物の私はすごい頑張り屋なんですけど
今日は瞑想していないで寝ているのは
もうそれは睡眠不足のせいであって
本物の私のせいではありませんと
私にもう面接するんですね
だから面接に来ても無駄
だから私は不機嫌になりますし
言ってる通りにやりなさいということで
言ってる通りやってないんだから
妄想しているんだから
それで聞くのはこれ これ眠気あるんですけど
なんかいい方法ないんですか？眠気をなくすという
私は寝られないようになるためにどうすればいいかと人に聞く
あんまりにも馬鹿馬鹿しいんですよ
その通り もうもうずっともう眠気があって
歩く瞑想してるんですけど
歩いていてももう寝ているんだと
どうすればいいかと それぐらい知識人で私に聞く
で もう自分が眠たくて
こうやってこのもうものすごい強烈にもう 二十四度のに部屋を暖めて
で 部屋の中でちょこちょこちょこっと歩いてるだけです
外は寒いし そこで堂々と歩くことも眠気なんかもうもう飛んでいくでしょうに
それを私に聞く だからすべてそういうもう自分をそのまま肯定して
私が本物はすごい立派で
これ何とかしてくれないのかと
あまりにも無知な世界だから
非論理的で無知っていうことは
この明確にじりじりと見えてくるようになりますよ
だからそれで理解してほしい
やっぱり人間っていうのはそこまで馬鹿やと
もうもう恥ずかしい もうないんだと
これはもうもうそれで自分に気付いて気付いて悟りの方向に行くんですけど
絶対やらない そこで自我を捨てられますよ
だからこの私がいるという形があらゆる形をとってとって出ている
だから この 何ですかね
このあらゆる形をとる
この自我というか 私がいるという
瞑想うまくいかないと思ったりすると
うまくいかない どうやって思うんです？うまくやったことはもうないのに
それ自体がへりくつでしょうに
だから自分の自我で妄想でこうできればうまくいっている
そんなのは知ってるわけないでしょうに
言う通りにやらない人々はもうもう何百年やっても自分のやり方でやってますから
私がいるという前提でやってますから
まあ頑張ってくださいっていうぐらいになっちゃう
だからその場合でも私がいるんじゃないかっていうと
はっきりしちゃうと大丈夫ですよ
邪見もものすごくはっきりして
私がいると いうとエネルギッシュだから
それでは潰せますよ だから何かあったら潰せるんだからね
そっちのエネルギーは機能してないんだから
すっごくもうアドバイスできない
言葉の遊びではないんだからね
言葉を超えたところの世界ですからね
私にもこれやという風に言えるならばありがたいんですけど
それは言えないですね
まあ一応瞑想なんかやってるならば
もうあらゆる形で私はこうではないか
ああではないか なんでこうなってるんでしょうかとかね
ということが一応ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ妄想から妄想
妄想から妄想 妄想から妄想で出てくるんですね
全部妄想は全部どこから出てくるかというと
私がいるという我がありきという言葉
感覚から発生してくるのです
それが煙と書いています
もうずっと煙っているんだと
どんどんどんどんもう煙を出しているんだと
悟った人にとってはもうアスミティビッラサティアスミ我がいるということはないんだと聞いてるんです
中は空なんです それは悟ったならばなんです
それだったらもうこうではないか
ああではないと 本物の私はそんなもんではないんだよとかね
怒ってもただ怒っただけとか
私は本体本来は全然怒りませんよとか
全然ないんです 私はという諸氏はなくなっちゃうんです
次にこのパッジャラティ
光も出しているということ
イミナアスミティビッラサティイミナイタスミティホーティイミナエワスミティホーティイミナアニャタスミティホーティという妄想が出てくるんです
こういうことによって私はこうなるんだそうと
こういうことでこうなるんだという世界が出てくるんです
このように 1 日 5回お祈りすれば
必ずしも天国に行けるんだとかね
わかりやすく言えば あるいはこの瞑想をすれば
まあ会社でバリバリ仕事をできるんではないか
そうするともう同僚にも認められて
上司にも認められて まあ安定するでしょうとかね
自分が瞑想すると 自分の子供をちゃんと躾できて
もうしっかり育てることができるんではないでしょうかとかね
そういう風にこの期待感で妄想をさらに続けるんです
だから 将来に対する期待感が続くところが光出ているところなんですね
もう炎が燃えているところなんですね
これでイミナ イミナ イミナという言葉がイミナっていうのは
今やっていることによってこうなるんではないかという意味なんですね
だから瞑想する時でも
瞑想したらこうなるんではないかという
それもものすごい期限なんです
こうなるんではないかと
それでお互いに仲間同士でアドバイスつけますから
その時は真面目に聞くんですね
仲間と言ったっても これ悪魔ですから
絶対悟らないようにアドバイスするんですね
自分も悟ってないんだからね
こいつはたまるかと 自分が妄想して作った幻覚なんか教えてあげるんです
精神的にいかれているから
ある意味幻覚が生まれてくるんです
それはこうなるんだ こうなるんだと言い続けてあげる
あ そうか そうか そうか
私もこのそれでこうならなくちゃとか
一人二人ぐらいなんか来て
すごい私に文句を言ったんですね
ずっとやってるんですけど
こうもなってないし こうもなってないんだよと
私は驚いて 私そんなこと言ったの？あんたに光とか見えると言ったの？言う瞬間で全部もうもうストーリーが見えるんだから
こちらにはね 誰が言ったっていうところまでは知ってますけど
証拠なしに喋ってはいけないんだからね
で もうしょうがないんですね
じゃあその人のやり方してくださいっていうことしかないんです
だから誰かがね 無責任で
だいたいこの未熟な人に限って教えたくて教えたくてたまらないんですよ
特に瞑想の場合は 能力ない資格ない人こそすっと飛んでいって
もう邪魔して先に行っちゃうんですね
私の指導を聞いているけど
同じ言葉で聞いているんだから
暗記できちゃってね 違うんです
それが 同じ言葉で誰にでもするんだけど
この働きが違います それをわかってないんだったら
これ瞑想指導できないんです
どうしても言うならば
まあ一応基本的なこういうやり方でやってますよってぐらいは言っても問題はないんですけど
で やってみて これはごちゃごちゃごちゃ聞くなよと
まあ一応やり方はこういうやり方ですよと
いうぐらいだったら もうブッダの真理を侮辱しようという気持ちはないんだからね
まあそれでは安全ですけどね
だからこの未熟である限りは
教えたくて教えたくてたまらない
教える資格がないならば
もうその人が飛んで教えるんですね
こういう風に自我の世界っていうのは
もう強烈ですよ なかなか大変なんです
それで修行するっていうことには
人に言われてなくても
本人もそう思っちゃうんですね
こうすればこうなるんではないかと
だから厳密な姿勢っていうのは必要なんだよ
だからこの悟るんだと思うんじゃないんですよ
例えば仏教の人であろうとも
悟るんだ あるんだ あれだこれだとか思うだけダメなんですね
すごいみんな清らかな心と心の平安を得たいとかね
それはとんでもない嘘なんですよ
だから平安な心 平安な心って何ですかね
無記録で生きてもないのに
イメージもそうそうできるはずもないでしょうに
だからお釈迦様のこれはアッパティハーリヤという言葉がありまして
こういう人間の思考というのはアッパティハーリヤというね
単語で表現していますけどもね
例えばある人が私は世界一美人と結婚するんだそうと言う
では あんたその世界一美人がどこにいるか知りませんよと
インドの質問だから これはバラモン色ですか？と
あるいはシャトゥー色
4色の中でどんなカーストの人か知りませんと
どこに住んでいる人か知ってますか？と
知りませんよと というと
何が言ってるんでしょうかと
私は世界一美人と結婚するんだそうと
世界一美人と結婚したいんだけど
どんな国の人かも知りません
住所を知っているところか
どうやって結婚するんですか？だから
何の経験もないとこをやるぞと思って
私はあの人と結婚するんだよと思ったら
それはなんとかなれるかなれないか分かるでしょうに
例えば日本の一般の方はあの紀宮様でしたって
今結婚決まってますけどね
私は紀宮様と結婚するんだそうと言ったってもいいんですよ
会ったことはないんですけど
でもどこにいるか知ってるんだから
生き物やと知ってるでしょう
あ どうぞ頑張ってくださいと言えるでしょうに
そこで頑張っても頑張って
やっぱり無理やと 他の人と結婚する予定やと思うで無理やってこれぐらいわかるでしょうに
それが具体的なんですよ
とんでもない妄想ってわけじゃないんです
だからこの人間 こういう実体性
具体性 何もないものを目指すっていうことは
もうまるにもうヘルツでもうちょっと成り立たないんですね
だから悟ろうとやるんじゃなくて
煩悩なくそうとやるんですよ
それが見たくないんで
私は完璧だからね だから自我が入ってきて
もう邪魔するんです 自分が眠気で妄想ばっかしてても誰しないと
それは自分ですよ それをなくそうとやってるんだから
どうすればいいかと私に聞くんじゃなくて
自分で頑張ればいいでしょうに
この状態だけはなんとかするぞと
次出てくるこの状態を何とかするぞと
次出てくるこの状態を何とかするぞというやり方でやっちゃえばいいんですよ
それでそんなことやって
あんた何を受けてわかります？そんなことは
それでいいんです ただ今この状態が最悪だからね
ずっとこの理性でやるんです
だからこの炎が出てくるという場合は
もうこうなる これでこうなる
これでこうなる これでこうなる
これでこうなるという妄想パターンなんですね
だから世の中ではもうこれしたらこうなるんだ
これしたらこうなるんだ
これたらこうなるんだという
そういう期待感に人をかけて
人の自我を応援するんですよ
で 本人がやっぱりそうなりたいと
それも自我なんです それで煙っていうこと
だから私がいるという
私が我があるという気持ちない人にとっては
そういう炎はないんですね
悟った人はこれでこうなるという自分に対して
もう客観的にもう水をこぼしちゃうと全部もう汚れますよという話じゃないんです
それはもう単なる客観的な因果法則だからね
自分に対して 私はこれをしてこうなりますよという
その私はという主語が危ないんです
それは悟った人にはないんです
次の言葉がこの四ページの
下から数えないとね 下段落ないんだからね
段落のように見えますからね
まあ二番目の段落はマハーヴァッコパンチュム
それはもう終わったっていう意味で
それは経典に入りません
その上の二番目 上から言えば三番目の段落ですね
カタンチャ ビッケーヴェ ビック アッパッジャハエティ
このパッジャハエティということも
日本訳すれば妄想するという意味になっちゃいますよ
でもそこでちょっと妄想
微妙に違う妄想なんですね
イデ ビッケーヴェ ビックのアスミ マーナ パヒーナ メーホウティ
アスミ マーナ 私がいるというマーナですよ
マンですよ 同じことですよ
私がいると思ったとたん
マナなんですけどね でもなんで同じことなのに分析したのかというと
インドでお釈迦様が宗教の達人さんに語っていたんですよ
すごい哲学者に だからこの経典
初めはすごい単純ですけど
終わりの部になってくるとぐっと難しくなるんです
で やはりインドですごい魂について云々と語る人々やら
それからあらゆる瞑想して
あらゆる超越した経験ある人々やらもいっぱいいましたから
みんなそのその自分の宗教の専門家で
プロで もう修行もいろいろそれなりの修行も進んでいてとかね
手強い相手方なんですよ
だから自我なしでマンなしに私ということを
私という概念なしに私を探す求める人々もいたんです
例えば真理が梵天梵であると
神であるというと その時点で自我が入れてるんです
一切一即一切弥陀と 今の自分というのはもう別にどうったことは
ただの海の一滴の水であってね
どうったことがないっていうことで
そこで慢がないんですね
ない ないようなんですね
なさそう だから 海の水一滴が波一つが私は別な存在やではなくて
海やというところが究極な境地やというふうに言ってる人々もいたんですね
その話 ウパニシャードに入り込んじゃって
もうかなり強烈に引き続けてはいますけど
波だと 本体 本体は海であると
海と波の差であると だから本体は梵我であって
個我っていうのはただの波で
波といったってもただの同じ本体の水そのもので
どうったことがない そうなってくると
あまり慢が機能しないんです
でも人類みんな哲学者というわけじゃないんですからね
みんなそんなに高度な宗教哲学を持ってるわけじゃないんだからね
だからだいたい自分が私がいるという時点で慢なんです
本当は だから慢の定義も私がいるということなんです
我がありきということが慢なの
慢です だから最終的な悟りで消える煩悩でもありますね
預流果に悟ったんだからと言って慢が消えるわけじゃないんです
一来果に不還果になっても慢は消えないんですよ
それで最終悟りで消えるんです
そこである比丘にはアスミマーナ
私がいるんだというマーナが消えている
慢が消えている ウッチンナムーロムー
根元から取っているターラワッタタとムー
タール木のようにしている
アナバーヴァかと また生まれないようにしている
再生しないようにしていると
その人はアッパッチハエティと
で もうそうしないんだろう
だから煙に例えると いっぱいゴーゴーと煙が出て
それから炎が上がって
それから炎も消えたところで
何て言いますか 大量に薪があって
もう火がつく場合は まずもうどんどん煙が出ていて
煙が出て出て それから炎が出て
その炎が出て燃えて 燃えたところでまた薪が
熾火  熾火というかね それもすごい強烈でしょうに
あなた 炭とかはそういう状態でしょ
炭は一旦燃えたものだからね
炎出して それで炭に火をつけちゃうと炎は出てこないんですね
ただ赤くなって燃えるだけです
その3番目のステージなんですね
で パッジャハエティというのは
そう どちらでも悟った人にとってはないんだよと
それで終わりますけど
まあ一応 普通の人間にとっては
ただ普通の すごく素直で
ごく一般的に そんなカッコつけないで普通に生きてる人々ってね
やっぱり喜怒哀楽の範囲内でもう生き生きして生きてるんです
その生き生きして生きてる人のこの生命エネルギーはね
最悪だからだって怒りから怒りが出てくるは
怒りから欲が出てくるは
欲から欲が出てくるは
欲から怒りが出てくるは
生き生きしてないんだけども
最悪もう不戦の世界なんですね
そこを完璧に改良すると
更生させるということで
完全に更生させるためには
そのエネルギーを欲から離れます
離れて集中しなさいと
集中するためには あらゆる概念やら言葉やら色々使わなくちゃいけない
しかし 瞑想しなくちゃいけない
瞑想して集中したら そこですぐ喜びを感じるんだよと
あれよりもはるかにすごい生き生きしたエネルギーを感じるんだよと
次にさらにさらにそれは強化していきなさいと
そうすると 第4 禅定になったら
ものすごい安定した平安の喜びもなく
悲しみもなく 心が強烈な心が生まれてくる
もうそれからさらに煩悩をなくすという方向へ持っていくと
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは
普通のやり方と違って
本物のヴィパッサナーは煩悩をなくすという風にやるんです
で 悟ろうとはやらないんです
で 煩悩をなくそうとすっごいエネルギーがついたところで
じゃあ煩悩をなくしてやるぞと頑張ると
煩悩が根こそぎから消えてしまう
で 消えたところで心は安定しているんだと
ただ欲から離れただけでも
あの振り回される状況からはもう自由なんです
欲から離れて心統一したら
もう怒りから怒り生まれることはないし
欲から欲が生まれることもどちらでもないんだけど
消えたわけじゃないんです
そこで煩悩もなくなったところでもうなくなった
消えたと もう二度とその状態が現れませんと
いうことで 悟った人っていうのはもう煙もないし
炎もないし 熾火もないんだよと
いうことで 悟った人の状況を説明しますね
その場合はすごい哲学的にこの我があるということが問題にしているんです
またうっさになりましたからね
あの なんていう 退席することもないし
攻撃することもないんだと
で 退席もしない 攻撃もしないで
やっぱり無気力で無関心ではないかと思っても
これ皆様が感じている無気力
無関心とは違う世界なんですね
今の世界で考え みんな無気力
無関心ですから それ悟りに近いわけじゃなくて
もう悟りと正反対なところにいるんですね
エネルギーがないんです
だから戦争に戦争 日本では負けだと言わないんですね
だからいまだにやってますからね
一応戦争に負けちゃって
敗れちゃって もう全て壊された時は無気力でしたかと
じゃないんですよ 戦争した時はもう全く無知でアホで愚かで
もうとにかくやっつけてやるぞという
そのエネルギーがあったんです
怒り 憎しみのエネルギーが
そこは潰れたところでエネルギーだけ残っちゃったんですけど
もうどうしようこともできない
手に手も足も何も出ない状態で
そこでそのエネルギーのおかげで平和ということで
もう50年の間で社会を作っちゃったんですね
それでそのエネルギーを使い切っちゃったところで
今またただ壊れていることになっているんです
だから 自然の流れではもう一度日本人に戦争がなければ復活をできないんですよ
まだ誰かを殺してやろうと思わないと
もう起きてこないんです
だからそこを破壊的なエネルギーしか持ってない
だから今そのエネルギーももう未亡でもう機能しないことになってるんだからね
だからまあそういうことで
それはそれで だからこのただ無関心
無気力っていうことが危ないんですね
これはもうブラックホールになったんだから
もう構成できん 構成できるエネルギーを持ってる人だったら
とにかく逃げた方がいいんです
ブラックホールから 自分のエネルギーまでなくなっちゃいますから
だから 悪くてもいいんだから
生命エネルギーは持ってほしいんですね
引き締めてほしい 行動的で活発的で
間違っても失敗してもどうでもいいんです
その生きるエネルギーを改良して
良い方向へ導いて そこで強烈なエネルギーが澄んだところで
全て無常だからいいから諦めなさいということで諦めるんですよ
そうもうエネルギーの頂点に達しているんです
そこでさよ諦めるんであって
だから仏教でいう無関心というのは
俗世間での無関心とはものすごい違う
こちらでは無記禄ってことを平気で言ってますけどね
もう煙もないし もうおきみさえももう消えてるんだと
いわゆるもう無ということでしょ
機能なしっていうことですけど
まあそういう順番でまあ一応終了いたします
はい どうもどうもありがとうございます
[エンディングミュージック]